the White House is insisting it is
aiming to completely block Iran from
ever acquiring nuclear weapons while
powers and Iran agreed last week on a
framework for final negotiations to take
place in June they say it will
effectively curb Tehran's nuclear
programs so that it can only be used for
peaceful purposes such as electricity
generation in return Iran will see
crippling sanctions lifted that there
are still details about the phase-out if
you will of the sanctions that have not
yet been agreed to and it is the strong
view of the administration that it would
not be wise and it would not be in the
interest of the international community
to simply take away sanctions take away
all of the sanctions on day one well the
Obama administration has ramped up its
campaign to try to get backing for the
deal with Iran but it has drawn
criticism from congressional Republicans
and also the Israeli government and
skeptical Arab allies of the United
States for the national security analyst
to arish aramith now live via from Los
Angeles great to speak to you Irish
let's talk about Israel first Netanyahu
benyamin Netanyahu the Prime Minister
there says that any deal with Iran would
be a bad one is that feeling shared by
the majority on Capitol Hill do you
think well it's probably shared by the
Republican majority at least a majority
within the Republican majority on
Capitol Hill while we have to save it
for those of us myself included but but
times been critical of the Obama
administration and this deal I gotta say
we have to be realistic and getting a
deal with Iran that would completely
take Iran back to a nuclear stone age
was just going to be impossible I I for
one think this is while it's an
imperfect deal with a lot of
imperfections it is a pretty good deal
of that if enforced and if Iran sticks
to its end of the deal and carries out
its end of the bargain it guarantees the
world a pretty safe non-nuclear weapon
eyes Iran so I think that in yahoo's
expectation from the very GetGo were
sort of unrealistic but when you bargain
when you come to the bargaining table
you want to
set your goals really really really high
so what a compromise is reached you sort
of meet your adversary halfway on
Capitol Hill though it's a different
story while a lot of congressional
Democrats and a lot more Republicans are
not very happy their frustrations is
made their frustration is mainly over
their lack of trust for the Iranian
regime and for its activities in the
past 36 years and also some lack of
trust and President Obama's ability in
his administration to actually enforce
this deal that was hashed out in
lausanne switzerland last week this
difficult balancing act isn't it we were
hearing earlier that President Obama has
spoken to his counterpart in Amman as
well at the Gulf states saying that that
whilst getting this deal with Iran is
possible and he wants to pursue these
diplomatic options he's also said that
he will address Iran's destabilizing
activities in the region so it's not
just Israel that's concerned about
Iran's activity is it it's the wider
region as well absolutely many Arab
states in the Persian Gulf region are a
more afraid of Iran's expanding sphere
of influence than they are about Iran's
potential nuclear weapons program so it
is not necessarily that the Iranian
nuclear program that scares the Saudis
or the Emiratis or the Bahrain ease for
that matter it is Iran's expanding
influence in Yemen in Bahrain in Iraq
and Syria and Lebanon in sort of all
over the Arabian Peninsula and much of
the Persian Gulf most of which is
oil-rich and most of which is surrounded
by a Shiite minority even though the
Shiites are minority in the Mideast and
also and Islamic world they constitute a
majority of the oil-rich resident
sections of the Persian Gulf area so
it's very important to see the fear of
society fears the spheres of other Arab
states in the Persian Gulf but also the
this is a very complicated situation the
United States can no longer say the
enemy of my enemy is my friend there are
factions fighting in Yemen that hate
each other hate the Saudis hate the
Iranians
and hate us the who thiis for instance
are very anti-american very anti-israeli
supported by the Iranians and guess what
they're also extremely anti-isis and
anti al-qaeda so you see it's a
complicated delicate and de fragile
situation I think Saudi Arabia's
involvement in this endeavor is a
lose-lose situation if they didn't get
involved in yemen yemen would have
completely fallen out of their control
would have been a Houthi / former
President Ali Abdullah Saleh coalition
that would have taken over the country
and now that they are involved and if
they do in fact get inside a ground war
in Yemen it doesn't it's not going to
look pretty for Saudis who haven't seen
combat or not combat ready and also
they're going into the poorest country
in the Arab world and I'm not sure
exactly why so Iran is pretty much
opened a new front in this proxy war to
drag Saudi Arabia in while Iran has been
dragged into Iraq Syria and Lebanon